it's really weird to be a woman of the
year at 17 that's like the first thing I
can say not weird just amazing Vili
Eilish is night at the Billboard Music
Awards was just as epic as you'd expect
starting with her speech the old
speeches where long as
oh my god I'm sorry I'm sorry they've
been beautiful honestly
Nikki speech was the most beautiful
thing I've ever heard she looked fine as
hell too as always
yeah Dean Billy of course she praised
all the women who won awards just before
she did what Taylor said earlier was
beautiful I see that fire in the newer
faces in our music industry I see it in
Liz Oh
Rosalia Taylor Parks do a Lipa LM a
Billy Eilish what Alicia said I loved
Alisha I was just saying outside this is
one of the most the energy in this
surrounding billboard women in music is
so powerful by the way if you missed it
Alicia Keys and Billy had quite the
special week I just feel like there was
such a genuine love between us like for
real no boat and it came across and I
think people adore her so much and she's
really just allowed showing people how
it looks to be comfortable being
yourself yeah the cutest but back to
Billy speech she also gave a shout out
to ariana grande ariana grande got the
award that I'm getting right now
a year ago and she gave a speech that I
thought was like the most touching thing
I'd ever seen and like two weeks ago I
realized that's the award I'm getting
and that really freaked me out and her
love for re really does run deep just
like I'm gonna grind like what like that
girl is like the king
Billy also thanked women in general for
paving the way for her I want to thank
all the women in the past who have been
the reason that I can be the way that I
am and do what I want and like paved the
way for me and an entire generation of
young women who in the past have like
done what they weren't supposed to do
has made my life a lot easier before the
night got started women in music
couldn't help but praise Billy on the
carpet why is she so cool what is it
she's just like got that natural vibe
that we all want and deserve to have but
she has it I admire her for that and we
were able to just connect and bond and
it just feels like a blessing and inside
the show celebs posed with Billy check
out this shot with her Nicki Minaj and
normanni
here with Cyndi Lauper and it doesn't
get much bigger than this next pic that
I'm about to show you Taylor Swift's
with Billy aka the woman of the decade
and the woman of the year
legends meeting legends just want to add
we knew Billy was gonna be a big star
when her debut album dropped and so did
chief are you ready for the next level
of superstardom no no I think I am
honestly no I think I I feel like I feel
like I am feel like I always have been a
little bit without really realizing it
your destiny I love that cheers to Billy
and all the women at last night's women
in music event for all the latest on
Billy Taylor Nicki and your other
favorite ladies keep it locked to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
crass and bye for now
[Music]